>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> I was tremendously impressed
by Slaughter's writing skill,
by her sense of place and character,
and most of all, by her seriousness.
There was a lot of violence
against women in this novel,
but it was never gratuitous.
It was an angry woman saying
this is what is happening
in the world and we need to stop it.
I gave the novel a rave review
and predicted great
things for Karin Slaughter.
Happily, I was right.
I'm not always right.
Her subsequent novels about
Sara Linton became bestsellers.
And more recently, she has written
three excellent novels featuring
special agent Will Trent of the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation.
Her most recent novel
Broken, her 10th novel,
actually features both
Will Trent and Sara Linton.
There are a lot of outstanding
women crime novelists today.
We could mention Sue Grafton,
Sara Paretsky, Laura Lippman,
Elizabeth George, Martha
Grimes, Denise Mina in England.
Karin belongs on that list, and it's
a pleasure to present her to you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you readers and
people who are just inside
because this is the only shade.
[Laughter] I've been
told it's getting cooler,
but I don't believe it.
And I'm from Georgia so this
is sort of like winter for me.
[Laughter] I wanna start
before I talk about myself
and how wonderful I am
by saying that we're
in a real national crisis here,
and probably you're
thinking, "In what area?"
because there are so many areas
in which we are in crisis.
But I wanna talk a
little bit about libraries
and how important our libraries are.
I don't know any writers who
didn't get a start in a library.
And you know, in the south,
especially, because there's--
when we were growing up,
we're the only buildings
that had airconditioning.
But the library is the
center of every community.
The people who use it in many cases
can't afford books, otherwise.
In rural areas, 85 percent of
the children in these areas,
the only time they have access
to technology or books outside
of school is in their
public library.
And we really need to do our
best as a community to make sure
that libraries stay
open and fully staffed
because being a librarian is not
just a vocation, it's an art.
And I know that I got my
start because the librarians
at my library saw what I was reading
and said, come over here, you know,
you need to stop reading
about the V.C. Andrews
and all these other books that are
routinely turned down in the corners
where the good parts are because
there are other books out there
for you, and they gave
me Gone with the Wind.
They gave me Nancy Drew,
Encyclopedia Brown.
They gave me the gift of my life.
And there are so many kids out
there who are gonna be denied
that if we let libraries closed,
so I want it open for them.
[ Applause ]
>> Now, I also wanna speak in
phrase of the lowly thriller,
and this is something
that I ask usually
at the beginning of
events like this.
Why is plot a bad thing?
The great thing about thrillers
is they have to have a plot.
They have to have a
beginning, a middle, and an end,
and that's what I like when I read
a story and that's what I write
when I sit down to write my books.
But it's interesting here because
the Library of Congress, of course,
is the center of this event.
And one of my favorite urban legends
or perhaps is not an urban
legend is the library of--
the catalog data for a book that
we all know, The Great Gatsby,
is filed in the Library of Congress
under Automobiles, Accidents.
[Laughter] And I think of that
when people ask me what
sort of book she writes.
They'll take one look at
me and they say, "Well,
do you write children's books?"
And I always say, "Well, my
second book had children die."
So-- and generally, she had
some up, I don't know why, but--
or they'll say who's your
publisher and I'll say Random House
and they'll say, "Oh,
that's a real publisher."
So I don't know.
Maybe I should dress better or
they always want me to be taller.
But I think I'm writing in a genre
that is the best genre in the world.
And if I told you a story
about a local community leader
who was very charismatic
and angry at the government,
and this vicious prosecutor
who wanted to bring him down,
and paid off a snitch to turn
him in and framed him for a crime
and eventually gave this
community leader the death penalty,
you might think that's
a John Grisham book,
but it's actually the
story of Jesus Christ.
Or if I told you about an alleged
rape in a small Alabama town,
of course, I would be thinking
of To Kill a Mocking Bird,
or a murderous elephant who
opens up like Water for Elephants
or the story of a pedophile
in Lovely Bones.
The interesting thing about
categorizing books is once a lot
of really smart and
educated people like them,
they stop calling them thrillers.
And so my goal now is for you
to take away this one thing
that thrillers are the
best books in the world.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
When I think about what the
form really is meant to do,
it's meant to tell
the story of society.
And when I think about my favorite
thriller authors whether someone
like Denise Mina or Mike
Connelly, or James Lee Burke,
or if I go further back to someone
like Flannery O'Connor who'd
really use violence in the form
of the Southern Gothic to not
just talk about violence per se,
but to use it as a fulcrum to pull
the scab off the human condition,
because that's what's
people are really writing
about when they're
writing serious thrillers.
They're writing about humanity.
They're not just writing
about people
who have awful things
happen to them.
They're writing about the
aftermath of violence.
And you know, part of that interest
of mine comes from being raised
in the south during the time
of the Atlanta Child Murders,
and even though I was
not the profile
of the victim during the
Atlanta Child Murders,
I was probably the furthest thing
from it, I was terrified as a kid,
because when you're a
child, you don't realize
that bad things can
happen to children.
And it changed my life
in very meaningful ways.
I was no longer allowed
to play wherever I wanted.
I started watching a lot more
television because, usually,
and anyone raised in the south knows
this, during the summer when you're
out of school, your mom kicks you
out of the house and locks the door
and says, "If you get
thirsty, there's the hose."
When they stopped doing
that, we were allowed to stay
in our houses during the day,
and so it really changed my life,
and it made me interested in writing
about how these life-changing
crimes occur
and what the violence leaves behind.
Another reason I think I'm drawn
to this genre is my grandmother
loved telling everybody secrets.
Now, she would have a heart attack
if we told hers, but, you know,
when I was a little girl she
loved taking us to church.
And my parents didn't like
me to go to her church
because they had basically
stopped handling snakes
about a year before I was born.
[Laughter] And they put the
primitive in Primitive Baptist.
And my grandmother
loved showing me off.
And you know, every Easter Sunday
we would go to church with her
and she would say,
you know, at the end.
She would introduce me to
her friends and I'd be there
in my little Patent leather shoes
and my underwear with a little lace
on the back which is
very uncomfortable
in the seed I might add.
And she would say, you know, this
is Ms. Harris or this is Ms. Jones,
and then as soon as the woman
turned her back, she'd say, "Well,
you know, she's a drinker."
[Laughter] Or you know,
"Her husband is cheating
on her with the gardener."
You know, there was always
this dark, dark thing.
And another thing
that my grandmother loved was a
magazine called True Crime magazine.
This probably is still published
today, but it's an awful,
awful magazine that's
basically violent pornography.
And the covers would always have
a woman on the front, you know,
looking over her shoulder
and the headlines would be
"She Should Have Listened
to Her Husband"
or "She Should Have
Never Left the House."
And inside were all these
horrible true stories of women
who have left the house and
we're subsequently murdered.
And this really tied in to stories
my dad told me when I grew up.
As the youngest of three girls, he
really realized early on he needed
to keep us in hand, and so most of
our stories that he's told us were
like the little girl who left open
the kitchen door and was killed,
or the little girl who left
the heat on and was killed.
[Laughter] So you can see why
I come by this very honestly.
But my grandmother loved reading
these True Crime magazines.
And one year, I had the great idea
that we would buy her a subscription
for Christmas because she
had to go to the trashy store
on the other side of town to get
the magazine 'cause it wasn't sold
at our store.
And so we bought her this gift and I
was right there at her knee waiting
for her to open up the little
card, and she read it and she burst
into tears, and she said,
"I don't want the mailman
to know that I read that."
[Laughter] And so I think that
here we are many years later,
at a point in our lives, especially
as women where we can admit
that we're interested in
reading about these things.
>> We wanna know about violence.
We wanna know how people
respond to it.
We want to know how it changes them.
And that's really the
focus of my work.
Pat, who's a wonderful man, by the
way, a wonderful writer on his own
and an excellent reviewer,
and I don't say
that just 'cause he
gave me a nice review.
But, you know, the wonderful thing
about crime fiction today is--
especially with women
writing about violent crime,
I think it's really changed
the tone of the genre.
And I think in many
ways, it's made men
who write crime fiction even better
at what they do, because before,
I think, in the '80s and '90s,
women in crime fiction written
by men were only there to be
saved or to have sex with.
And now, women go toe
to toe with men.
And Lee Child is one
of my favorite authors
and I think he's an
excellent example of this.
The women in his books are so
strong and they go to reach her
and they face up to him,
and he respects them
and that's why I liked reading
a Lee Child book, you know,
as much as men can
identify with that sort
of James Bond wonderful
Jack Reacher thing.
I think women can identify
with the fact
that Reacher really respects women.
And that's a wonderful thing
to read about in crime fiction.
And I try to do that in mine
because I think it's important
when we're writing about topics such
as child abuse or domestic violence,
or that sort of thing, to
show that women are strong
and that they're survivors,
and that they're quite capable
of saving themselves.
And so I hope when you read
my books that you really see
that that's what my focus is.
And before I open up to questions,
which hopefully you guys
will have 'cause we got a lot
of minutes left [laughter] and
warm up act for Scott Turow, so,
you know, throw me a bone here.
My next book that's coming out
next summer is called Fallen.
And I got the idea for Fallen
because I was lucky enough to be
on a training exercise
with the agents
of the Georgia Bureau
of Investigation.
And what they did is they took
over an abandoned school one day
and they had a simulation where
there was a school shooter.
Now, before Columbine, and
actually during Columbine,
the procedure when there
was a school shooting,
was to go to the school
and establish a perimeter,
and then go from classroom
to classroom to classroom
and clear people out,
clear out the wounded.
Now, as we saw in Fort
Hood, the procedure is go
and kill the person
who was killing people.
And so instead of being a standoff
that lasts for hours, it's something
that only lasts usually
a few minutes.
I think the shooter for the woman
who took him out, took him out maybe
in three minutes after
she got the call.
And so I was going with these agents
as they were being trained to go
through the school and look for the
shooter and take out the shooter,
sometimes kill him, sometimes just
subdue him and get him on the floor.
And they have role players
and they had people screaming
and people saying, oh,
this child's been injured
or this teacher needs your help and
the agents had to ignore all of this
and just find the shooter.
And many of them were distracted.
I was distracted as I
followed them through this.
And the remarkable thing to me
was the longest anyone took to go
into the school and take
the shooter down was
about a minute and 22 seconds.
And if you think about
the lives that are saved,
that's really a remarkable thing.
And I think I feel-- I felt really
fortunate that someone who lives
in Georgi and has nieces
and nephews in schools
that they were doing this, that they
were practicing to do this because,
of course, unfortunately,
it's gonna happen one day.
And what I felt when
I was following them
through was this huge
rush of adrenaline.
And when I got home I thought,
I really wanna write about that.
And so when I started
writing Fallen,
I wanted my detective Faith Mitchell
to have a similar experience.
It doesn't happen at a school.
I haven't just ruined the plot for
you, so please still buy the book.
[Laughter] But I wanted to talk
about that adrenaline I felt
and really get in to the story.
And it opened up so many different
avenues of this character just being
in that kind of situation.
And I think that's why I
love my research so much
because it gives me the opportunity
to walk in the shoes of someone
that I never would, otherwise.
And it was just a thrill to do that.
So hopefully you guys
will enjoy and read it.
And now I beg you, please,
have some questions.
Anyone?
[ Applause ]
>> Good afternoon.
I wanted to know-- well, I agree
with you that plot is important,
but it's your characterizations,
I think,
is why I really buy your books.
I just love them and I
wanna know two things.
One, are Will and Sarah
going to get together?
[Laughter] And two, Will's
disability and where that comes
from in terms of-- perhaps your
background or interest or-- ?
>> Well, I could only
answer one question,
so I'll answer the one about Will.
[Laughter] You'll have to
read the books for the other.
My sister had dyslexia and she
wasn't diagnosed until she was 30.
Well, not officially diagnosed.
Before that, she was
diagnosed as stupid,
and really that's what the
teachers told my parents
and the great private
school system in Georgia.
That's what they told my parents.
And so we did think that
she was just not very smart
as we were growing
up and she's lived
with that stigma for a long time.
And when she finally
got the diagnosis,
she said to the doctor,
"I can't read this.
What does it say?"
But she said, "Thank you because
all these years I just assumed I
was stupid."
And she's really one of
the smartest people I know.
And so, I wanted to write
a little bit about that
and that's what got me
thinking about Will Trent
and making him dyslexic
and making someone
who has a disability the hero.
Because, normally, in fiction,
when someone has a disability,
they're either a maniacal killer
or they are someone you
should feel sorry for.
And I don't want anyone to
ever feel sorry for Will
because he's really a
quite capable person.
And as I was investigating
dyslexia to write more about it,
I was looking at the
symptoms of dyslexia,
and I thought these are
really the characteristics
of a very good detective,
very puzzle oriented,
very problem solving, very cued into
emotional cues, that sort of thing,
and so I wanted to incorporate
that into his character
and hopefully I have.
I've had a lot of positive
response from people.
And I think it's important
because in a lot of books, usually,
you can tell who the bad guy is
because they don't like greeting.
And it's sort of like in Hollywood
you know it's a bad person
if they smoke.
And so this is my double
bluff on people, too.
>> Thank you.
Yes ma'am.
>> Could you comment on the
character of Lena and the types
of complexities that
you've developed for her?
She's difficult character
to actually engage with.
>> She is.
And you know, honestly, people
either love Lena or hate Lena,
and that's how I wrote her because
I wanted you to know as a reader
that it's okay not to like
a character sometimes.
I want you to always read for her.
I want you-- sometimes, you
may wanna shake her and say,
"Why are you doing these
horrible stupid things?"
But she's also a woman who
was sexually assaulted,
and I wanted to write realistically
about the recovery of someone
who was sexually assaulted,
and I haven't ruined the plot
for the first book because
that's what happens to her.
But a lot of people
assumed she wouldn't be
in another book after that.
And to me that's when her
character got interesting,
and she gets into a
really bad relationship.
She drinks too much.
She does a lot of things that women
who are sexually assaulted do.
And again, it was a response to
something I was reading in a lot
of books where if a woman
was sexually assaulted,
you were either supposed
to just think of her
as someone who's pitiful or you were
supposed to wait for the strong hero
to come in and make beautiful
love to her and cure everything.
And so, Lena was the
response to that.
And I really worked hard to
make her as complex as she is
because this is something that has
defined her life for a long time,
but I think in the latest book,
she's learned to defined it
in other ways, maybe
not positive ways,
but she's certainly taken
more control of her life.
>> Thank you.
Yes.
>> Hi. Thank you for your comments
about libraries, first of all.
And also, people who read a lot
of series, sometimes they feel
that there's maybe an agreement
with the audience and the author,
and in one of your books,
I was completely shocked.
>> Please don't spoil it.
>> I'm not going to.
But I wonder if you
had any resistance
when you were thinking
about doing that.
>> Well, it's hard to talk
about this without giving a way
of a major plot point,
but I did something
that some people don't agree with.
And they-- you know, I got a
lot of nasty e-mails from people
and I wrote back to all of them.
And you know, the first thing
they said was, "Oh, wow.
We didn't think you would write
back," which I thought, "Aha,
yeah [laughter] just goes to show
you you should be a little nicer
when you write these e-mails."
We read these books to be
shocked and to be thrilled
and to be surprised, and if you can
say I didn't do any of those things,
then I would probably think in
my head that you were lying.
I wouldn't say it to your face.
But I-- here's the thing.
No one wants to read
about happy people.
You think you do, but
you really don't,
even when you read Anne
Tyler, you're not reading
for the happy people,
you're reading for--
you know they're gonna be
happy somewhat in the end,
but you want them not to be
happy for a really long time.
[Laughter] And if she
was writing a series,
they would never be happy ever.
You know, that guy,
that dog would be dead
by now from accidental tourist.
>> So that's a way of talking
around it, but I did on my--
if you're friended with me in
Facebook, thank you very much, but--
so I wrote a letter online
explaining why I did some
of the things I did in the books
that you can find, and if you can,
just e-mail me and
I'll send you the link.
>> Hi. Just for the record,
that letter that you wrote online
was what kept me reading your books.
>> Oh, it worked.
>> Yeah. I did.
I was just-- because I've been
reading you for a long time
and getting your newsletters
which are hysterical,
and you-- I mean you're a goof.
[Laughter] How do you--
I don't know.
It's just funny to find someone
who writes things that are so dark
and realistically horrible
that could be
so nuts-- I mean [laughter].
>> Well, thank you, I think.
>> I know.
It didn't come out quite like
I mean it, but [laughter].
>> I hope.
[Laughter] Well, you know,
maybe because I have this
sense of laid-backedness.
If I could make up a word, I'm
able to write these things.
Yeah. [Laughter] But,
well, that's a nasty laugh.
Where did that come from?
[Laughter] But all the crime writers
I know are great goofy people.
I mean Michael Connelly,
Harlan Coben,
I mean they're just silly guys.
Stephen King is just a big old goof.
On the other hand, no offense
to my colleagues here today,
but romance writers can be some of
the nastiest people you've ever met.
[Laughter] And I think--
we weren't even talked
about those drunks in
the children's booth.
[ Laughter ]
>> But I think it's cathartic.
I think we get it all
out on the page.
And so it means that we can be
nice to people and open the doors
for all ladies and do all the things
that you're supposed to do anyway.
And for me, it is very cathartic,
but I've always had this
interest in dark things.
And I don't think that's in direct
opposition to my personality.
I think it's-- believe it or not,
I think there's a lot
of humor in my books.
I mean people maybe not--
few would ever think that.
And I wrote a book called
Martin Misunderstood.
And some of my Amazon reviews were
"Karin Slaughter, you're not funny."
And you know, "Stick to writing
what you know" and all this stuff.
So, when I've tried to
inject some of my humor
into this particular
book, it felt spectacular.
So perhaps I should just keep
all my darkness in that one area
and not cross over
though it's being made
into a movie, the Second Monkeys.
Yes.
>> Do you have a routine
as a writer?
You write in the morning
or in the afternoon?
Do you do your research
first or as you go?
>> Well, I research
all the sex myself.
[Laughter] I wanted to see
what the sign was for that.
[ Laughter ]
>> I wish I had a better
routine than the one I have
because when I was writing
before I was published,
I had to do it whenever
I had the opportunity.
And I was very careful to structure
time before work and after work,
and-- 'cause I had a real
job and I had to do that job.
So now, I kinda work that
same way, I have a cabin
up in the Blue Ridge Mountains and
I go up there and sequester myself,
and I just work from 8 in
the morning until 8 at night
or however long I can and I do
this couple of weeks at a time,
and then I'm so exhausted
I never wanna write again,
and I have to go home and live a
normal life, and then I'm back.
And, you know, about 5 years ago I
heard myself complaining about this
and I thought, "Well, gosh,
it seems to be working.
Maybe I should just keep doing it."
So I wouldn't recommend anyone
write this way, but it works for me.
Yes, ma'am.
>> So I was curious that the
physician that you picked to be one
of your main characters
was a pediatrician.
Could you talk about why you picked
a doctor that deals with children?
>> Well, when I first
made Sara a doctor,
I thought that it would be good
for her to be a pediatrician.
One because-- I mean, honestly,
women tend to be pediatricians
and I wanted to use that construct
because when I was growing
up in Jonesboro, Georgia which was
a very small town when I was there.
The only role models we had were
school teachers, our nurses.
And I remember when my mother
took me to the dentist once
and there was a new dentist
and that was a woman,
and I laughed because I didn't
think a woman could be a dentist.
And so I wanted Sara
to be a pediatrician.
I wanted her to deal with kids
so she would know a
lot of people in town.
Pediatricians know stuff about you
that you would not want them to know
because your kids are
loudmouths and they're indiscreet,
and they'll say things like
mommy was taking a shower
with the postman this
morning or, you know,
so anything you think is a secret
your pediatrician or your school,
your child's teacher knows it.
Maybe a librarian, be careful.
But I thought it would be good
for her to have consciously chosen
to leave Atlanta and
be in Grant County
to be a role model for children.
And in one of the earlier books, she
says that's one reason she doesn't
like Lena Adams is because Lena
is the only female detective
on an all-male police force,
and she thinks "You're supposed
to be a role model and
you're the worst role model
for these little girls in town."
And I wanted Sara to have that
pride in what she was doing
and to have made a conscious
choice to do what she was doing.
>> Thank you.
>> Anyone else.
Well, I'm gonna get
the little things
and this is all the time
you have pretty soon.
So I would just like to say
thank you very much even--
maybe if you're not happy with
some of the choices I made-- oop--
wait, we got another question.
>> I heard it too.
I didn't get your signature
today because--
today because I didn't wanna be
like cards blacked [phonetic].
>> Yeah. Well, it was
hot over there.
I don't blame you.
>> And then my next question is
are you gonna do a stand-alone book
without Sara or Will?
>> I made you a stand-alone book.
I wanna write about
Amanda Wagner in Atlanta
in the 1960s being a cop
'cause this was the time
when the clans still ran the police
force, and this was the time--
well, not until 1962 could a black
officer arrest a white person.
And so-- I mean-- and you know,
this was shocking to me to realize.
And I'd been investigating
the police force
and doing a lot of
research into that.
And I wanna write specifically about
what it's like for women to be cops
because it hasn't changed that much
because women who survived during
that time where the women who sort
of macho'd it up and didn't show any
of their femininity because-- and a
lot of women here probably know this
in their own line of work, but, you
know, it's okay for a man to throw
up or be disgusted at a crime
scene, but a woman will not do that.
And I thought to this one
police officer who just retired
and was a cop in the 1960s and
she said, "I never peed on the job
because if I knew if I asked to go
to the bathroom, they would say,
'typical woman.'" And
I thought, well, one,
your bladder must be
bigger than your head.
[Laughter] But I thought it'd
be really interesting to write
about that 'cause I grew up
on Cagney & Lacey, you know.
>> I have one more question.
Every-- you only write once a year?
>> One book a year, that's right.
I'm sorry.
You want it to be good, don't you?
>> Yeah. [Laughter] Thank you.
>> Thank you.
Well, let me-- so let me finish
it by saying I'm doing the job
that I wanted to do since I was
a kid, and I don't think a lot
of people get to do that, but I
had a signing a little while ago
and this woman came
up to me and said,
"I went to kindergarten with you."
And that's the worst
thing you wanna hear
if you're an author 'cause you
don't remember them 'cause you're
in kindergarten.
And she said, "You know, I remember
you because when the teacher went
around and said, 'What do you
wanna be when you grow up?'
You said you wanted to be a
writer and you're a writer today."
And I'm the only other person in
class who answered that question
that day and is doing exactly
what I said I wanted to do.
"And you know, hats off to you for
being a writer and hats off to me
for being divorced from
a really wealthy man."
[Laughter] Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.